A few announcements at the beginning
today. This is 3.
91. For those of you who are new to
the class, welcome.
A couple of administrative things.
When you joined 3.091, regardless
of what registration took place
outside, please check in with my
office. I want you to check in with
either Hillary or Lori who will
assign you to a lecture section.
There is a lecture now Monday,
Wednesday and Friday at 11:00.
There is also a lecture Monday,
Wednesday and Friday at 1:00. And
we are trying to level out the
populations so that they balance the
seating capacity.
And also, likewise with the
recitations. We have recitations
that run all day long Tuesdays and
Thursdays. The earliest one is at
9:00, the latest one is at 4:00.
And, again, we are trying to
balance the occupancy there so that
we have good access to the
recitation instructor.
So please don't go squatting.
We need to know what the
populations are.
And that office is just down the
hall here in 8-201.
There it is. They are supposed to
take that light out,
but maybe by the end of the semester
a miracle will occur.
So why don't you look over here.
There is the coordinates 8-201.
And talk to Lori or Hillary.
There will be a test on Tuesday
based on homework one; ten minutes
at the beginning of the recitation.
You are allowed to use on the test
the official version of the Periodic
Table of the Elements which most of
you should have by now.
There was a shipment that came in
partway through the day on Thursday.
If you didn't get a Periodic Table,
swing by the office.
It is just down the hall from this
lecture theater.
And you bring the Periodic Table
and the Table of Constants and a
calculator and something to write
with. That's four items.
Show up, sit down, and the first
question is does anybody have a pen?
We may not have that many pens.
So those are the four items. You
do not use an aid sheet on the
weekly test. Aid sheet is for the
monthly tests,
not for the weeklies.
I have asked all of my recitation
instructors to state office hours.
And I, too, will have office hours.
So if you want to come and see me
Monday 3:30 to 4:30,
I am just down the hall.
Come in and see me. If you can't
come by at that hour,
you can send me email and I will be
happy to meet with you.
And I mean that.
I get to meet a lot of people
through the course of teaching,
and I recognize a lot of faces. I
can't say I will remember
everybody's name,
but I will recognize you.
And the same thing with the office
hours for the TAs.
The office hours are a time when
they will be seated waiting for
visitors. That means they will not
look at their email,
they will not take telephone calls.
They will be sitting there waiting
for visitors.
If you cannot make the office hours,
again, contact the recitation
instructor to make other
arrangements. Yes?
STUDENT: Is there a limit to the
type of calculator one can
use during the test?
No, I don't care.
The question is there a limit to
the kind of calculator?
I don't care. You can bring a
mainframe in on a truck.
I don't care. [LAUGHTER] It
doesn't matter.
A big calculator,
you know, I am holding you on your
honor. I am assuming you haven't
loaded the Encyclopedia Britannica
into the memory.
It is a calculator,
so aid in computational efforts.
What else do I have to tell you?
The readings. Well, here is the
homework. This is what it is based
upon. And we were issuing those.
When you go to sign into the class
you will get a copy of this.
Some people asked me, if they
bought the earlier version of the
text, you can find the translation
to the earlier version of the text
on these question numbers.
And if you go to the website and
look down here, Fall Term '02.
Go to Fall Term '02 and those
homeworks are listed bilingually.
Last year I listed them, and there
were not that many people that had
the First Edition of the text.
But if you have the first edition
of the text, go to Fall Term '02 and
it will show you the earlier
translations. In preparation for
lectures, I urge you to do some
reading. And so up here you look at
lecture topics.
It is the second button down.
And you will get to a page that
looks like this.
And so, for today,
for example, it says Classification
Schemes, Mendeleev,
Atomic Structure, Readings Chapter 1,
Chapter 2, Appendix A.
I don't cover everything in there,
but you are not in high school
anymore. You are going to read,
you are going to learn, you are
going to come to lecture,
I am going to hit some high points,
things that I find particularly
interesting, but it is not sort of
well, he said we are going to read
this but then he didn't talk about
it in class. Well, get
over it. [LAUGHTER]
Now, when you starting looking for
next week, you are going to see
reference to a chapter,
which is in the core text,
and you will also see this LN,
LN, LN archives. These are archived
lecture notes that were written by
my predecessor,
Professor Witt. And if you go back
to here and click on Archive Notes,
it is the fourth button down that
will take you to something that
looks like this.
And then if you look at Archive
Notes number one this
is what you will see.
In some instances,
these notes are superior to the text.
There is a reason for it.
3.091 has a syllabus that is unlike
general chemistry taught anywhere
else on the planet.
That is why you paid so much money
to come here. You didn't pay money
to come here to take something that
you could get just anywhere.
That is the good news. The bad
news is there isn't a text that fits
this syllabus,
so we choose readings from various
sources. And the text that I have
chosen is the best of a bad lot.
It at least overlaps to a greater
extent than most of the other books.
And using the text plus these
archive notes,
I think you will be able to piece
together what you need.
And there is a third alternative.
I don't know if you know this.
Maybe on the campus tour they kept
you away from this part of the
campus, but if you go over to the
east close to the river there is a
building called "the library."
And you know what they have in the
library? They have books.
And if you go into the library you
could find books on topics that we
are discussing here,
and you could read on your own.
But I wouldn't dare suggest
anything so radical.
Oh, by the way, speaking of text.
My office got a call from the
purveyors of text,
Quantum and The Coop.
And I don't work for them,
and this purely a courtesy so that
they will know what
inventory to keep.
Could I have a show of hands of
people who are planning to buy the
text but haven't done so yet?
Would one of the TAs count, because
I don't want to.
Just hold your hands up.
I am going to keep talking.
We just want to get a rough idea so
we can tell me they need to have
another 20 or they need to have
another 100. Two significant digits
is good enough.
We don't need to know.
I think that is everything that I
wanted to cover.
Oh, yes. And,
of course, the Webcast is available
so that if you miss something during
lecture, or if you miss lecture
altogether you can go to the website,
click on Webcast and follow what
happened in lecture.
Let's see. Let's get on with the
lesson. Last day we started talking
about taxonomy and looked at
classification schemes starting with
Democritus, which was very
forward-looking,
and then the backtracking of
Aristotle. And I would
like to go further.
We started with just the seven
metals and carbon plus sulfur,
it was the point of departure for
Democritus. And the Aristotelian
view held for a long time,
but eventually it started to crumble
in the light of more data.
And, again, all of these slides
that I am showing all convert to PDF
and will be posted at the website.
So you can just watch, take notes,
but you don't have to copy every
last detail down.
By the time of the American
Revolution these are the elements
that were known.
And here we have arsenic,
antimony, and bismuth, three
delightful that were given us in the
12th, 13th and 14th centuries by the
alchemists. In 13th century India,
they knew how to isolate metallic
zinc. In fact,
there is a pillar there of high
purity zinc that stood for the
duration. It is almost a thousand
years now and it is in high purity.
Platinum was unknown until the
Spanish came to South America.
It was unknown.
It is an American metal.
Platinum is an American metal.
And, oddly enough, it was given a
bad name. Plata is silver.
So platina is like a diminutive of
silver, but we now know that
platinum is far superior to silver.
It is far more noble. It has a
higher melting point,
a higher chemical inertness,
a fantastic metal. An American
metal. And then all of a sudden we
have discover,
discover, discover,
discover. What does this mean?
Are we saying that until 1774 there
was no oxygen because it was
discovered then?
No. What does it mean?
It means that it was isolated and
characterized.
Lavoisier characterized oxygen.
Cavendish characterized hydrogen.
And so now we see the shift from
craft to science.
Now we have all this data,
and this Aristotelian model is
looking goofier and goofier.
So we need to have some better
explanation.
And one of the earliest was that of
John Dalton. John Dalton was an
Englishman who proposed the
following classification of the
elements. John Dalton's science was
very accurately weighing the
elements. He has arranged the
elements here in a column.
It is a double column, but it is
only made double for convenience.
You can see, it starts with
hydrogen and goes to mercury in
ascending order of atomic mass.
And he was very proficient at
measuring atomic mass.
And, furthermore, he started to
abbreviate. Instead of writing gold
he made this symbol.
Silver was S with a circle.
He could have worked on a ranch out
in the West, couldn't he?
This looks like branding things,
don't they? Well, this is
interesting, cute fonts,
but in point of fact they were
short-lived. Berzelius,
the Swedish chemist suggested that
the French might take umbrage at
having to use I for iron.
He said why don't we choose
something neutral?
Let's choose Latin,
the language of scholarship,
and so iron became Fe for ferrum and
lead became Pb for plumbum and gold
is Au for aurum and so on.
And nobody quibbles because nobody
speaks Latin so it is neutral for
everybody. John Dalton also talked
about other things.
He said I am going to propose a
model. And this is right out of
Chapter 1 of the text,
1803. These are the planks of his
model, that matter is composed of
atoms that are indivisible
and indestructible.
Well, doesn't that sound an awful
lot like Democritus?
He is taking us back.
He is getting us out of that
Aristotelian rut and moving us back
to something that makes more sense.
All atoms of an element are
identical, that's good.
Atoms of different elements have
different weights and different
chemical properties.
This is important. The word
"property" is really important - to
connect the concept of property with
something fundamental in the make-up,
in the constitution.
What I am doing,
listen to me, I'm talking at two
levels here. I am talking at the
level of this is Dalton's model,
but then there is a meta knowledge
here of how you develop models in
general. If you are trying to model,
I don't know, the efficacy of a
particular drug,
these are the baby-steps that you
will go through.
Atoms of different elements combine
in simple whole number ratios to
form compounds.
That is important,
that elements, because they are the
building blocks,
they combine in whole number
multiples.
If you have a set of blocks,
mechanical, physical blocks, and I
tell you to build something and I
say, oh, by the way,
you have to cut the blocks in
smaller pieces,
you are going to get angry,
aren't you? You are going to say,
well, I thought these were the
blocks. These are the basic blocks
so, therefore,
whole number ratios is a consequence
of that. And,
lastly, this is Democritus that the
being is made of particles that are
eternal. This is eternity here.
Atoms cannot be created or
destroyed. And when a compound is
decomposed, the atoms are
recovered unchanged.
This is good stuff.
It was 200 years ago.
Just last fall there were some
events in the world celebrating the
bicentennial of Dalton's scientific
achievements. Oh,
by the way, just to let you know,
these scientists of that era were
polymaths. They were not
specialists. I am a specialist of
atoms that are left-handed on
Thursday afternoons,
and don't talk to me about anything
else. These people had broad
scientific interests.
Dalton did a lot of work on vision.
He, like many men, was afflicted
with red-green colorblindness.
And he developed the understanding
of red-green colorblindness,
and it is known as Daltonism.
The same man. Other
classifications,
Dobereiner at Jena talked about
triads. People,
remember, they were measuring atomic
masses. He saw that if you take the
atomic mass of chlorine,
add it to the atomic mass of iodine,
divide by two, you get something
that is really close to the atomic
mass of bromine.
And he did it for other triads.
And he found that the middle member
of the triad had an atomic mass that
was midway between the atomic masses
of the end members.
An attempt. You have to give him
credit. Second was Newlands that I
will talk about.
I like Newlands because he had a
musical flair about him.
He talked about octaves.
He said look at sodium, magnesium,
aluminum, silicon, phosphorus,
sulfur, chlorine,
potassium. One, two,
three, four, five, six,
seven, eight.
Potassium lies one octave from
sodium. He talked about octaves.
When he presented his results at
the sitting of the Royal Society,
he was ridiculed. He was laughed at.
He was derided.
Somebody rose and asked him if he
had considered putting the elements
in alphabetical order.
They were very cruel. These people
were nasty. They don't
welcome innovation.
Science is very hostile to
innovation when it challenges
existing theory,
sort of like management,
the same thing. Let's move onto
something that really took the giant
step ahead, and that was Mendeleev.
And I also want to mention Lothar
Meyer in Tubingen who came up with
the same classification scheme,
but we are going to see in a moment
why Meyer is not well celebrated
today and the glory to
goes to Mendeleev.
1869, Mendeleev,
here is a picture of him taken from
that period. He was 35 years old at
the time he enunciated this.
35, positively brilliant. Here is
his paper. It was published in The
Journal of Russian Chemical Society,
1869. And it is really great
because he actually goes through the
thought process for you
and describes --
I need to give you one piece of
background. Mendeleev played cards.
And he traveled by train. And so
to pass the time,
he would play solitaire.
He was used to working with cards
and putting things in rows and
columns by suit.
You had to find what is the
distinguishing feature?
Well, these are all clubs,
these are all spades and these are
all hearts. And I get down to a
certain card and I am stumped,
so I will leave a space waiting for
that card to appear on cue.
That is the background.
Here he is. He has all the
information he knows that has been
reported on the various elements on
file cards. He even carried them
around in his pocket and he would
look at them from time to time and
try to devise a scheme.
Remember the other people,
the octaves had been enunciated,
the triads had been enunciated.
Here he is in his paper and says at
that time I decided that it was
advantageous to find a more general
system of the elements and here is
my attempt. And here he
has laid them all out.
And he has left blanks here,
question marks here and says it is
advantageous to put them in rows and
to form a table.
And here is the smoking gun
sentence right here.
It says finally it came to place,
according to this concocted system,
and I've underlined in red, very
many undiscovered members.
So what does he do? He knows that
he shouldn't put arsenic under --
He shouldn't put arsenic under
aluminum. Arsenic is nothing like
aluminum. Arsenic is like
phosphorus. He takes those two
facts, plus the courage to leave
blanks, and this is what he gives us.
Lothar Meyer was doing the same
thing, but Mendeleev does something
more. He says not only does arsenic
belong under phosphorus,
I predict that there is an element
that lies below aluminum
and above indium.
And I will go even further and will
predict what its atomic mass is.
So he called them eka. Eka comes
from Sanskrit meaning one after.
So eka-aluminum is one after
aluminum. He predicted 68 for the
atomic mass. Gallium was
subsequently isolated 69.
. Eka-silicon, which we now know to
be germanium, 72,
72.6. He says there is an element
under zirconium, and it
should be about 180.
He said there should be an element
under boron. He called it eka-boron,
scandium 45, 45.
. It gets better.
He goes into excruciating detail.
This is his prediction for silicon.
I already showed you the atomic
mass. He said I predict its density
5.5. It was measured 5.
6. He says it will have a high
melting point.
Well, that is arbitrary.
It melts at 958. It forms a
dioxide, has a high melting point.
And he predicts the density of the
oxide of the yet undiscovered
element. And he gets it right to
two significant figures.
And then he says the tetrachloride
will be volatile,
and it will have a density of 1.
. And subsequently germanium
tetrachloride was synthesized and
measured to be 1.
8. That is why we celebrate
Mendeleev. What we are seeing here
is a big transition from just
experiment and documentation to
modern chemistry.
And how does modern chemistry work?
Well, first of all, look at the
data.
We always have to look around us and
account for all the evidence.
And this is an ethical question,
people. Sometimes you get data that
throw you off.
And it is so easy to dismiss those
data. What you have to do is have
the courage to say I have got to
account for the bad data,
what I think are bad data and the
data that helped me build my theory.
So you recognize patterns and then
develop a model,
and most desirably a quantitative
model. A quantitative model that
explains the observations,
obviously.
But what Mendeleev did was he came
up with a model that not only
explained what we observed.
It made prediction. And it made
predictions that can be tested.
I would love to make predictions
that you cannot test.
Well, let's make predictions that
can be put to the test.
So this is modern chemistry.
I have told you about the table of
the elements. Why do we call it the
Periodic Table?
We'll again go back to the website.
Down here is a button called
Courseware. If you click on
Courseware you will get to this menu,
the first of which preferences is
Periodic Table.
If you click on Periodic Table,
you can get a variety of choices.
One of them here I happened to
choose is boiling point versus
atomic number.
Mendeleev is the one who taught us
that the properties of the elements
are a function of the atomic mass.
So let's get that down.
By the way, the Cyrillic to Latin
translation has not been agreed upon,
so you will see Mendeleev's name
spelled many different ways.
You will see it spelled like this.
You will see it spelled like this,
like this and so on.
And so, when you do a search,
it is sometimes frustrating. But I
will use various forms.
Mendeleev wrote the following.
He says that the properties of the
elements are, or let's say vary,
the properties of the elements vary
periodically with atomic mass.
We will find out later that is
almost correct.
There is a slight variant on there.
But right now I am going to give it
to you as Mendeleev enunciated it.
Atomic number, we will learn later,
is the improvement. That is why
this says atomic number,
but for most intents and purposes we
can say this could be atomic mass.
What I am looking at here is
boiling point as a function of
atomic number.
And what we see is it is not
monotonic. It is not continuously
rising, continuously falling.
It seems to rise and then fall.
And then it rises and then it falls.
And then it rises
and then it falls.
And it rises and then it falls.
And, if you laid this out in a
table, as Mendeleev did with his
cards, you would find that the local
maxima all occur roughly in the same
horizontal position from the end
points of the rows.
And then there is a trend going
from least massive to most massive.
So that is where the "periodic"
comes from. We have a table of the
elements with properties varying
periodically with atomic mass,
so we compress all of that
information and refer to it
as the Periodic Table.
Here is atomic radius versus atomic
number. You see the radius is high
and then it falls.
It rises, it falls.
It rises, it falls. It rises,
it falls. We are going to now go
into the atom and try to understand
the scientific basis for this
observed behavior.
And so here is the Periodic Table
in its glory today following on
Mendeleev's scheme.
The elements have been named up
through --
The one that you are getting hasn't
got the latest information.
This was named over the past summer.
This is element 110 which has been
named darmstadtium after Darmstadt.
And I will tell you why in a minute.
If you do look down at the Periodic
Table and get above 109,
you will see these strange notations
here, Uun, Uuu,
Uub. What is all of this?
These are elements that have yet to
be isolated.
These are elements that are unstable.
These are what are known as the
superheavies. Elements beyond
uranium, these are synthetic.
And where are they made? The
manufacturing facility.
There are three places on the planet
that have the high energy physics
equipment in order to make these,
and these are the three places. One
is Dubna in the former Soviet Union
in Russia, one is in Darmstadt in
Germany and the third one is in the
United States in Berkeley.
These are the three places where
they have the accelerators.
And the kinds of reactions --
Here is how they were able to make
darmstadtium. They take an atom of
lead, accelerate it and have it
collide with an atom of nickel.
And, if the conditions are right,
they will combine, fuse and form
darmstadtium plus neutron.
So these devices, when I was a
youngster, were colloquially known
as "atom smashers",
because they have the capacity to
actually break these and
have them reform.
And there are various forces that
play in the nucleus that will
dictate when this will be stable and
when it won't be.
They isolated it,
but it decays very quickly on the
order of microseconds.
Lifetime on the order of
microseconds. So,
you can imagine, that is why we
don't have the boiling point of
darmstadtium and its electrical
conductivity. They have isolated it
enough that they can actually say
the bare minimum about
it. So we have it.
And then, just so that you will be
literate in the rest of the Periodic
Table, if you look at the higher
ones, this is how you name them.
Use these Latin prefixes. 111
would be un plus un plus un.
So 115 is ununpentium. That is why
you see these Uup,
Uun. My favorite is 111 because
that is unununium.
I am going to be sad when they
finally get a name for
it. There they are.
And, when they are named,
they are named by suggestion by the
scientist who have isolated them.
And there is a lot of competition.
Obviously, if it is Russian team
that isolates the element,
they are going to advocate the name
of a Russian scientist or a Russian
location or whatnot.
Obviously, the work that was done
to isolate 110 was done in Germany
and they proposed the name Darmstadt.
And, hence, it is named
darmstadtium.
There is a dubnium and there is also
a berkelium. And,
if you look in the very high numbers,
you will see these nomenclatures.
There is darmstadtium sitting there.
For reading, if you are really
curious about some of this early
history, I can recommend this book.
It is "Mendeleev's Dream." I read
it the summer before last.
It has a lot, of course, about
Mendeleev. But what is really
interesting is the author assumes
that the reader hasn't taken 3.
91. And so the first three chapters
take you through the history of
chemistry starting with Democritus.
And it takes you through to the
Aristotelian theory.
After you have had these lectures,
it will be a joy to read. Now let's
go inside the atom to try to
understand what is going on.
And this is taken from your book,
Table 1.3. And so these are the
subatomic particles that we have to
contend with. We have the electron.
It bears a negative charge and the
value of minus 1.6 times
10 to the 19 coulombs.
This is the SI unit,
the systeme international unit for
electric charge.
And it has a mass of 9.
1 times 10 to the minus 31 kilograms.
The charge compensation comes out
of the nucleus with the proton and
it is positive 1.
times 10 to the minus 19 coulombs.
But its mass is 1800 times that of
the electron. The electron is just
a little gnat in comparison to the
proton. And then there is this
third species, the neutron,
which has no charge.
Roughly equal in mass to that of the
proton. And so what we do,
in order to designate the identity
of an atom, is the following.
This is the atomic symbol which was
given by Berzelius.
This is the Latin one or two letter
character. And we began with the
proton number.
The proton number is in the lower
left corner. Z proton number.
Number of protons in the nucleus,
this is number of protons in the
nucleus, which in the neutral atom
is equal to the number of electrons.
Now, to get to the number of
neutrons, what we do is go up here
to the upper left.
And this is called the atomic mass.
And it is equal to the sum of the
number of protons plus the number of
neutrons. So we get at the number
of neutrons indirectly because we
know the proton number here.
This is sum of protons plus
neutrons. And we don't put the mass
of the electrons because they are so
light in comparison.
This will give us the sum that we
need. And, at some level,
there is some redundancy here.
If we want to write sodium, for
example, sodium 23, 11.
Well, 11 means it is sodium.
If you have 11 protons, it must be
sodium. We could get away with just
23 Sodium **23Na**,
but if you wanted to be a real
smart-aleck you could write sodium
like this. You don't need anything
here. Just a suggestion.
Now, atoms need not be neutral.
They can be charge deficient or
charge excessive.
And so Michael Faraday coined the
term "ion" for atoms of net charge,
atoms and other species bearing net
charge.
For example, the positive ions,
these are electron deficient. We
cannot do anything about protons,
they are buried in the nucleus, but
we can add or subtract electrons.
The positive ions are electron
deficient, and these are known as
cations. And you can use mnemonics
to try to keep these straight.
I see the T as sort of a plus sign.
It comes from the fact that in an
electrochemical cell,
the cations are those that are
reduced. You know from catastrophe,
cata is Greek for down.
Catastrophe is a downturn.
So that is the cation. The
negative ions,
these are electron-rich.
They have an excess of electrons.
And these are known as anions. It
has the n, which might conjure up
negative, or anion and minus both
have five letters.
I don't know how you want to try to
keep those straight, but anyway.
Those mnemonics sometimes come in
handy. All right.
Now the last thing is that because
the neutron has no net charge,
we can change neutron number.
Neutron has no charge.
This means you can vary the neutron
number without changing chemical
identity, because chemical identity
is fixed by the proton.
And since we don't have to charge
compensate, we can add or subtract
neutrons at liberty.
And so you can look,
for example, at the Periodic Table.
And, if you look up the atomic mass
of carbon, you will see that carbon
comes at 12.011 for carbon.
Well, isn't this against Dalton?
This thing is supposed to be a
whole number here.
But, if you look more carefully,
you will find that this is a blend
of three different forms of carbon.
We have carbon 12. I will even
leave off the 6 because we already
know it is carbon.
It has to have 6 protons.
So carbon 12. We know that it has
the proton number,
by definition, is 6.
And the neutron number,
6 from 12 is 6. So it has 6 protons
and 6 neutrons.
And it is the dominant form of
carbon.
So its abundance in nature is 98.
92%. There is a carbon 13, however.
It axiomatically must be 6 protons,
and it has 7 neutrons.
And this found in an abundance of
about 1.108%. And then there are
the last four,
carbon 14, which is a radioactive
form. And we will talk about that
later in 3.091.
And its use in radiocarbon dating.
And carbon 14,
6 again and it has 8,
and it is found in vanishingly small
amounts, 10 to the minus 12 or part
per trillion. If you add all these
up then you end up with 12.
11 as the atomic mass. They all
have the same Z,
the same proton number,
but different A, which means number
of neutrons varies.
That means they are found on the
same place on the Periodic Table.
If they are found on the same place,
it is iso-topos.
These are called isotopes.
Isotopes have the same chemical
identity but different nuclear
properties. What are the units here?
We write 12.011. It is
either grams per mole.
And I am not making a mistake here.
Most of chemistry has gone SI so
every mass should be in kilograms.
But occasionally there is this one
little remnant of the old CGS system,
centimeters-gram-second,
and this is one. This is 12.
11 grams per mole or 12.011 atomic
mass units, AMU.
And the AMU is defined as the mass
of one-twelfth of a carbon 12 atom.
I talked about this concept of mole
here. What is the mole?
Mole is a more practical value,
something that we can handle
tangibly.
And how do we get the value of the
mole? The mole is something that
was also defined in terms of carbon.
And the mole is defined as the mass
of, excuse me.
It is the amount of carbon 12
weighing exactly 12.000 grams.
You can see the atomic mass unit
will be, excuse me.
Let me go at it a different way.
This will be the definition of the
mole as the amount of carbon
weighing exactly 12 grams,
so I would like to know now how many
particles, how many carbons are
there in that mole.
And one way we can get to that is
by looking at two pieces of data.
The first one, again, is by Faraday.
Faraday conducted electrolysis of
silver. In an aqueous solution,
he passes electric current and
causes silver ions to deposit and
form metallic silver.
And he measures how much charge is
required. He has current.
We know that charge is equal to the
integral of current times the time.
And he knows the current,
he knows how much time and then he
weighs this. So he is able to
weighthe silver and compare it to
carbon. And, against that scale,
he finds the silver weighs 107 grams
versus 12 grams for carbon.
That is the ratio. Now, if he only
knew what the electron brought him
he would be able to divide through
and calculate how many species there
are in a mole.
And, in order to determine that,
we had to wait a few years until
1909. In 1909 Robert Millikan doing
experiments at the University of
Chicago conducted this interesting
effort where he took atomizer,
filled it with oil and then squirted
fine droplets of oil mist in between
two plates that could be
electrically charged.
He further charged the droplets by
irradiating. Here it is showing
x-rays. He used x-rays.
He used various forms of
high-energy radiation in order to
make the droplets bear a charge.
Now you have this situation where
you have a droplet that is net
negative or perhaps net positive.
And it lies suspended between two
plates.
And I am able to vary the voltage on
the plates making this for
argument's sake negative and this
for argument's sake positive.
If there is no charge on the plate,
these droplets will simply fall
under gravity.
Once the droplets are charged it
makes no difference.
They will fall regardless of the
charge. When the charge is applied,
if the upper plate is negative, we
would expect that the negative
droplet would be repelled at a rate
exceeding the gravitational fall.
The positive droplet,
its fall will be slowed and could
even be made to lift.
And so, by playing with a variety
of sizes, remember the atomizer is
going to give a distribution of
droplet sizes,
a distribution of voltages,
Millikan was able to develop a
relationship between the applied
charge and the observed velocities
of the droplets.
Let's plot droplet velocity as a
function of looking at the number
that have this velocity with the
zero being in the center here.
What do you expect is going to
happen? If there were no voltage on
the plates, we would expect
everything to be over here in some
negative value falling.
But what he found was a
distribution. He found
a distribution.
And, if you look more closely at the
distribution, here is what he found.
He found that some droplets had a
certain velocity,
and then others had a velocity plus
some step. And he couldn't get
values of velocity in between
certain steps.
He reasoned then that the charge,
since he could vary voltage
continuously but got a discontinuous
variation in velocity,
his conclusion was that the charge
must be discontinuously attached
to the droplet.
Out of that he concludes charge must
be quantized. Charge is quantized.
In other words, it comes in batches
of a certain unit.
Charge is quantized.
And, secondly, he was able to
measure the value of the
elemental charge.
We use the term element to mean the
lowest value. The element is carbon.
That is the smallest unit.
Chemically this is the smallest
unit of charge.
And he gave us a value that turns
out to be 1.6 times 10 to the minus
19 coulombs in modern times.
And the electron has a negative
charge, so we would say the charge
on the electron is minus 1.
. But I want you to learn this as e
being the elementary charge.
E is the finest charge that is
available to be attached.
And so now if we take the value of
the Faraday, Faraday found that to
get 107 grams of silver required 96,
85 coulombs. This is on the basis
of the integral of the current times
the time. And Millikan said that e
is equal to 1.
times 10 to the minus 19 coulombs.
This is coulombs per charge and
this is coulombs per mole.
If you divide the two of them
through you will get 6.
2 times 10 to the plus 23 per mole.
So this is how much charge there is
in a mole of electrons.
This is the number of carbons there
is in a mole of carbon.
And this is given the value the
notation N Avogadro **NAv**.
Avogadro's number we call it.
Avogadro was a professor of
chemistry at the University of Turin
who did a lot of work on gas laws,
understanding the number of gas
particles in a given volume at a
given temperature.
Isn't this nice? They name
constants after professors.
They didn't name it after a
baseball player. They named
it after a professor.
So now we know the Avogadro number
and are able to count the quantities
accordingly. What I am going to do
next day is go into the larger
stoichiometry and understand the
principles of mass balance and
reactivity. But before you go,
hold it, I don't want you racing off.
We should be going to 55 minutes
after the hour,
so I have something to share with
you.
I don't know if you heard this
morning, but there was news of the
discovery of yet one more element.
Anybody hear of it? I guess you
were busy. I got this off of NPR.
It says the discovery of the
heaviest element known to science
has been reported.
Obviously it has to be heavy.
All the light ones have been
discovered. The new ones are going
to be heavy, so that's great
reporting. The element tentatively
named administratium.
It has been tentatively named
administratium.
And this will have to go up before
The International Union of Pure and
Applied Chemistry before they
approve it because they fought over
element 106 for the longest time,
but I think this will go through
fairly quickly.
Maybe not. It has no protons,
so therefore, it has no electrons.
Because proton number equals
electron number,
which means if it has no protons its
atomic number is zero.
So you are learning already.
However, it does have one neutron.
It has 125 assistants to the
neutron, it has 75 vice neutrons and
111 assistants to the vice neutrons.
That gives it a mass number of 312.
The 312 particles are held together
in a nucleus by a force that
involves the continuous exchange of
meson-like particles
called memo-ons.
These memo-ons just go back and
forth. Now, there are no electrons
so there can be no electronic mail.
We speculate there may be neutronic
mail here. But,
anyway, let's talk about the
properties. Since it has no
electrons, it must be chemically
inert. However,
it can be detected indirectly
because it seems to impede every
reaction in which it is present.
According to the discovers,
the presence of a few nanograms of
administratium made one reaction
that normally takes less than a
second take over four business days.
Oh, there is more. Because it is
heavy you expect it is radioactive.
It has a half-life of approximately
three years at which time it stops
decaying. Then it undergoes a
reorganization in which the vice
neutrons, assistants to the neutron,
the assistants to the vice neutrons
exchange places.
And there are some early indications
that the mass actually increases
after each reorganization.
Now I will send you on the weekend
with a chemistry joke.
We have to have a little bit of
humor. I need it quiet,
though. It comes right over here.
Actually, this one. We have to put
the audio visual up.
This is the one you need.
You need this one right here.
Can you see this?
OK. Neutron walks into a bar and
sits down at the bar.
The bartender looks at him and says
I know you. You're a neutron.
He says, yeah, yeah, I'm a neutron.
Neutron is kind of quiet. Finally,
he looks up and says how much for a
beer? The bartender says,
"for you, no charge." OK. Get out
of here. Have a nice weekend.